is that when I try on jeans like when I
go try on jeans right yeah and then
we're in the Under Armour shirt right
now that's cool this is a James purse
shirt that's a dry fit Nike shirt with
no it's not it's a James purse
double-layer okay
it's made by a it's a it's it's stylish
surfer god damn it stylish can I finish
my yeah go
I was acted Janis and it's a beautiful
gunmetal grey what carry on it's a
cobalt grey it's dry fit it's a cobalt
grain it's not drying your John Danaher
oh you have no I know you're really a
grass guard Regine no I'm not that's
cool dude no I'm not that would be John
Danaher wears a leotard I don't where
they were as a rash good I don't know I
know John so what about your jeans I
enjoy this I like getting I like putting
on jeans a lot of times a lot of times
they're too tight on the old thighs okay
and I go like this I go how do these
guys fit in these jeans do they not are
they not athletes do they not do any you
say it to the work especially if it's a
woman I don't like it my legs you do my
legs are too even that it's always a guy
sometimes a woman's always a guy
sometimes a woman yeah so you tell the
dude I go I don't get it man well I
don't get a man my legs like do these
guys not do sports and I can't squeeze
into these because you want the guys are
too big you want the guys you go you
need the athletic you know hey go they
go well you can't you can't fit in the
skinny I go I can't fit in skinny jeans
yeah and I get a quiet deep satisfaction
of having to go get into the old elastic
once cuz my thighs I say to him ready I
got like this I got a weird body done
this to women I go I got a weird body
cuz I got a small waist but I got up my
butt sticks out and I got big thigh yeah
yeah yeah prom man yeah the skinny waist
but you know blood ass fat dick in the
front thighs
yeah I go I see him over the fat get
squeezed into jeans for guys who don't
do sports yeah and at 53 you rocks out
that's how I get off yeah and then I get
out then I go down you should go to an
urban mall and see how that works out
for you well like what yeah that's true
yeah yeah I don't like that don't do
that I go to white guy malls I go to the
white guy John Varvatos you know where
there's like lots of skinny jeans
involved and I go can't fit me sorry
Johnny
with a bigger leg in something in room
for the ass cuz I I got it I got that
bubble buddy in the rocks off and I got
I got calves on me - I can't squeeze
into these with my scans a comedian
zalenski he's also an actor see this
bright there's no background in politics
zero but he plays like a guy who and TV
okay he woke up as a president cuz he's
anti-corruption so he talks about
anti-corruption a lot anyone by a huge
huge landslide like seventy something
percent Wow look that's nuts he has no
background in politics but yeah similar
Donald Trump in he'll be dealing with
Putin now though yeah good luck with
that
yeah is this any different than Trump
winning in America he has no background
politics whatsoever um the only did like
you say everyone's artist near there was
actually a businessman who ran companies
so yeah but neither one has a background
politics true it's true Trump Spacey a
celebrity who won this guy's a comedian
who won it is a little just people once
change yeah
why is it different cuz Trump brand
business do you know this guy played a
president on TV Trump yeah it's a little
bit different Trump is very keyed into
tax law real estate the economy in that
sense he had to make it work he had to
deal with politicians all the time
remember in New York is a real estate -
yeah - even politics I'm saying but he
doesn't have a politician background
yeah
yeah but he had an idea of how politics
works because he had to deal with them
yeah it's all criticism Kanye because of
uh you know he's performing his church
ceremony and the coachella are they
criticizing how much he's charging for
merch yeah $225 for a shirt $50 for
socks and they're very very plain look
here's the thing they're these heavy
cotton tees my kid don't sell those our
shirts are more expensive these shirts
to make so they're that heavy like meaty
like I forget what they call it like
heyn heyn it's like but heavy cotton
which so it's really nice material no
it's bad it's the thick like school like
yeah concert tees where you wash them
they're [ __ ] like they're not gonna last
50 ostrich socks
$225 for the sweatshirt and it's all
religious stuff - so that kind of adds
to it
kind of says Holy Spirit like in this
weird writing this is Sunday service on
the back the problem is that my problem
whatever if you're gonna sell it and
that's the peak that's the market sell
it but at least make it the good quality
man yeah it's the [ __ ] quality that get
you yeah he's making out killing off
that you know I mean we're in the merch
business so we've been through this yeah
like you if you did the try bloom which
is real salvage what we do they last
forever they're soft people like to wear
those you won't want to buy it and we're
now cuz it's so crunchy church clothes
alright
crazy but that's that's the market right
people getting by it so he just keeps
doing it what happened our energy go
down low energy the way you sit gives me
low energy yeah well I tend to be a
little bit cross there yourself
got it no no I got a clear with the
professional I was gonna say Slayer
displayers
it's lit up yeah now do you get it done
it there's a woman named Camilo comes to
my house who's a fan of the fighter and
kid her boyfriend's a fan of our vodka
Oh was oh yeah and she she she brings it
down for me it's just that what happens
to me is I'm in my hotel room on the
road and I go I've seen you cut your
need a haircut riding and doing things
need a haircut and then I start cutting
I don't know I just thought well you
don't with your hair you can't just go
to anyone know like I can go kind of
[ __ ] with anyone yeah for me it can be a
disaster designers it takes too much
often never coming yeah where they cut
the to short along here and I'm like
listen sir I have a very long head so
now I look like Johnny long head this
lady uh not the lady from habit can
either not to know she just she said you
guys there's another guy named Daniel
who's fantastic
who cuts my hair you'll stick to one
dude he's so busy he's never around but
he's so great he just kind of goes yeah
I told you my dad passed away yeah yeah
it's a heart attack for kids so now you
had a new guy forget his name but he's
[ __ ] Puerto Rican speaks zero English
really Puerto Rican huh
definitely involved in some other
business by [ __ ] with him mmm-hmm I
don't know where else to go
it's tough man I had a guy she cuts his
own hair I can do it you can do what I
could do sweet fades I can't have you it
would be weird
just feeling it cut here it sounds a
little kid my mom taught me wow I got my
son's hair bites do it to me it layered
me up like this I get a little I do it
fades with clips I have a nice he's not
about fades not ok I can't do a thing
I'm too old for that and also you don't
wanna shave this side of my I look
terrible
I don't look I don't have used to have a
shade head for a long time yes as far
back as I can remember I've had as far
back I've had bad hair when I was 13
years old my friend held like touched my
hair and he goes that feels like hey
right now I had bad hair long blonde and
bad my if I hear keeps going out well
now I don't know because I can get it a
little bit in college we decided grow
hair I mean they mine's a straight from
jew-fro really up Jewish bro yeah I look
like a little Dickie if it keeps going
my son Sears curliest [ __ ] do ya now
it's the summer I like to cut it like to
shave it down shave it down he looks
good with a little looks like the old
Navy SEAL oh yeah yeah his grandma's mom
hey Donna know about it really they like
the crazy long hair I don't know you
gotta keep it short
well that's the show thank you guys
thanks guys my grandfather say that yeah
your ears aren't Sean dude have you
years Sean here's not Sean so again I
wish I had a wide nose I was if I was
gonna have surgery be a wider you ever I
can breathe but you got a big old nose
yeah yeah you gotta breathe now do you I
know is this completely different you go
back and look like you're not an
ultimate fighter out of very sharp
pointy nose you did look very Jewish you
got a very well people have asked me if
you're Jewish
yeah Jewish women go as he drew cuz shop
could be a Jewish name or very German
there's right here man was shop yeah you
know that no look it up okay but again
I'm not pleased I know I think maybe
brothers the original Samoan my nose was
broke in that picture that exact picture
see but my nose is pointing are there
how look at that nope its head surge
already there may be sure maybe
yeah it's pointy ER young man there
that's good tation swole hazy steroids
got some tits on you yeah
crazy pictures look at that was he was
he cool before the fighter were you
talking Mary he looks like he's just
smiling lady I don't know bro [ __ ] no
I have no idea what's up man I guess I
don't know yeah my nose used to be way
more point here though flattens out over
time your nose and ear the only things
that grow yeah ah your nose nears that's
what they like it keeps growing
I think so here Nicolas Cage he got
married to his girl of a he was dating
her for like a year
this is Japanese chick he's hilarious
and then he was drunk and you should see
the video I'll play the video for you
soon they're in a courthouse in Las
Vegas trying to get married he's like
yeah she try to get all my money he's
talking to other people in the crowd try
to get all my money he's drunk and she's
like I didn't tell you to do this I
didn't see how to do this anyways after
arguing the day of the wedding well as
you're in line in the courthouse to get
married to get their license astok so
then four days after or even before four
days he asked his lawyer to get an
annulment because he was a mistake
obviously all right he's hammered
hangover style and of course she says
she's fine with the annulment but she
needs spousal assess spousal support so
she's okay with the divorce but she's
requesting spousal support but they've
been together for a while
four days a year but married for less
than for like four days yeah
is that her on the left there no no no
she's a thought oh wow Japanese grow
great he's really super in Asians and
he's like notorious in k-town he's
awesome because he buys castles and like
nights and like cold swords and Nazi
gear and [ __ ] it's cool
literally the video please well that's
his outfit look at his hair amazing
Wow such a good actor god he's one of
the best but never has an end well after
they got the license dude they got an
argument she took off in a cab like
literally as they were leaving the
courthouse
yes her name is Toph man ho look at her
nervous
so he's probably completely bummed it's
just uh
that's him in the corner Sal takes her
face off she's a drug dealer as a
boyfriend yeah he's talking about her
ex-boyfriend and this from daily no wow
they ended up do wrong yeah they did get
their I still decided to go through it
after this one let's go come on romantic
he looks so fun that romantic - dude him
in leaving Las Vegas oh my god what a
brat woman yeah yeah
Wow it's not doing well no well yeah
that's him no it's not what does Sheila
see he does a bunch of movies does a
bunch of random movies his movies you
know he went broke some are on demand
had some real problems for a while yeah
he's buying like cat straight up tasks
oh yeah my friends he's over here my
good friend is super good friends with
him and I've heard some really
interesting stories he's a great guy
like white guy just that access that
insanity yeah it's great like what are
you doing why are you buying an emerald
tree boa and why are you buying caviar
from what are you doing like he's
probably made a fortune to afford just
well the best actors of all time yeah
hilarious awesome but his hair is tough
man yeah man when you see my back rip I
pull myself up like a champ like a champ
30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift